Jennifer Lopez performs her final show
at Planet Hollywood in Las Vegas but I'm
not sure which was the biggest spectacle
Kay of the show or these outfits here
that she and her man Alex Rodriguez Ward
to the after-party you saw all over them
listen to me the outfits were perfect
spectacular gear for a spectacular night
of that everything about it was amazing
off the charts and I spoke with JLo just
moments after she took her emotional
final bow
[Music]
you mentioned the support you've gotten
the mallets and how many shows and see
[Applause]
is it time time for what you know what
I'm what time is all about yeah I tried
to slip in that when are you getting
married question but JLo does not black
listen to have a partner who's that
supportive it comes to that many shows
it's a grind it's it's being away a lot
and he really makes the effort so do I
to kind of be there for each other and
it means a lot to me
from JLo's pre-show ritual to a rod
wearing a face mask before getting in
his all pink Tom Ford suit this couple
made J Lo's last show all about family
there he is trying to bust a move with
Natasha and then
[Applause]
my life right here Maxine Emmy brought
their mama to tears when they surprised
her on stage you rehearse that and
everything huh yeah I was super
surprised I had no idea that was gonna
but that wasn't the only surprise LL
Cool J jumped on stage for their 2002
duet all I have the name of her Vegas
show then at the after-party came this
JLo reunited with her ex Diddy who
attended the show was a-rod jealous not
at all
the two shook hands JLo smiling the
entire time finally looking back on her
three-year Vegas run at Planet Hollywood
this is what the 49 year old says she
learned it just taught me like when you
approach things when you go out I'm
gonna make this the best show that Vegas
ever seen and when you're doing that you
can actually make the production singing
and dancing in the show are off the
charts and you know what they want her
back oh I'm sure they do
[Music]
[Applause]